so tell me what are the pink pistol pink
pistols is a national LGBT self-defense
organization we're heavily focused on
training the LGBT community and armed
and unarmed self-defense why did you
first purchase a gun for a lot of people
Orlando we made individuals question do
I need a firearm for self-defense people
wouldn't have died if someone was there
and had a gun there's no guarantee but
it would have changed the odds you know
when seconds count the police are often
minutes or hours away a 100 pound female
has a chance against four linebackers if
she's carrying seems like an oddly
specific situation for linebackers one
100-pound girl and then she'll pick up a
I don't know how guns works like an
equalizer
would you consider yourselves
politically liberal conservative or
neither my views are probably some of
the ones that line up with the gays from
the 60s and 70s where it's like hey man
look mom and dad kicked you out you know
no one wants you you know you're going
to have to move to the city kid and
you're on your own but this is the
opening scene from rent yes it is yes
how does it go 525,600 minutes the cops
will take the guts in a vial fYI own a
gun and what do liberals not understand
about gun ownership if someone is living
in an area that is safe where they
perceive to be relatively crime free
that's a very elitist attitude to define
how someone chooses to defend themselves
to be a gun owner is not supporting
violence it is an identity so Second
Amendment in gun control issues is
really an issue of identity politics
strangely yes was it harder to come out
as a gun owner or as a queer person I
feel more accepted as a gay guy in the
gun community than a gun owner in the
gay community when we try it you come
out to me as gun owners
all right so something really important
I got to tell you cool babe I'm your
broad yeah top need you understand I own
15 guns
I say what bro I own 15 guns I wish that
wasn't as accurate as it often is okay
we've been through some good times and
some bad times it's a weird times yeah
Amsterdam there is a part of me that I
have been hiding from you
and I there is one thing that you could
say that would make me stop loving you
and I there's no way there's no way it's
true of you I my daughter you're gonna
oh that was the thing the one thing ah
all right Piper samosa there's something
that I've been wanting to tell you I'm a
gun owner Oh Piper hell no hail to the
knobs and now Piper to the food to them
no no no no no no no no no no no no but
uh Mystica stop thousand six hundred
minutes Oh Piper Oh Piper I love you no
matter what
thank you
[Laughter]